one of them is throwing fire
bob you're on fire okay got one oh both
of them they're both on fire
okay so as far as i know this
goes to like some boat door or something
yeah a hole oh there i go there we go
there we go
oh i'm alive was this all bust well
[Music]
looks like we've reached the end
there's got to be like uh some other
like offshoot cave or something here
like some way to go is there anything in
this big pool of water
oh this isn't very big oh there is i
think that's a [ __ ] cave right here
there's something oh
where like right under me there was like
some rock oh yeah there's a cave
entrance
whoa really i don't have a rebreather
though oh god
oh my god you guys check it out tell me
how good it is it goes very deeply down
okay
but but i would need the rebreather
right wait but it's like a cut scene to
get through here
wait what yeah but there's stuff to swim
under here as well right
okay well one second wait let's see
where it goes and then
i think the rebreather isn't oh man i
would hate to have to go back for it
though
i'm assuming you're supposed to have
gathered all the stuff to progress at
this point
yeah what cave had the rebreather in it
maybe it's not far wasn't
it called scuba cave or something scuba
cave
is there a cheat code to give you the
rebreather
no idea i think there there might be
actually but i literally got the tanks i
just don't have the actual thing
yeah bob i think if there's an option to
turn on cheats
and i think there's definitely a way to
get an item or like get old items
maybe we could do that once we figure
out where this goes well i imagine i
mean that's the only way forward we've
been able to find down here
yeah okay how do we activate cheat codes
i just turned cheap on okay so there's
got to be like a console command
let me look up okay so you're going to
open up the console
oh you got to be in the menu press menu
then f1 no that didn't do it either
damn it ah okay so you have to be on the
main menu and you have to type
developer mode on and then do it
developer mode on from the main menu
from the main menu
so we'd have to literally lose our
progress right now then uh
yeah so let's not do that um why isn't
there a way just to like force a save
that's what i want to know why is this
thing gotta be so deep oh no
if i starve to death down here i'm gonna
be so mad
i just need four sticks okay
first real quick you can save it here oh
thank god oh thank goodness do we need
to sleep here to get it as a save point
no no no just just save all right exit
the main menu
i'm gonna exit the main menu and if this
doesn't work then
mysteriously uh forrest was done
we did it
is it just add all items yeah all one
word add all items
we just type it that's upon us it's
inside of us gotta go
oh into the water boys oh in the water
in the water
oh my god i'm down
oh my god don't let it end like this
it's not down
it's not down oh it's in the water it's
in the waters in the waters and the
water's in the water dying is it dying
is it dying
oh maybe oh my god okay so now do we go
into a menu or just type it
wherever oh my god press f1 and type at
all items
look at your inventory
oh my god oh my god
oh wow where the hell is there a modern
bow
whoa repair tool
pistols we did it gang we did it hey
wait you got one of them rebreathers
i do all right you guys the only things
we didn't have from this were
a couple of the bows like some of the
weapons but like and head bomb
i don't know if you saw that yeah but
most of the keys
all right guys you ready to go here we
go i feel ready
wee i feel spicy
i feel very intelligent and skilled at
this game
this might not even be like the right
way to go for the end we're just like
we're gonna go find the flintlock pistol
down here
uh oh nice drawing uh there's a dude
looking at me funny
you shouldn't be doing that
that did less than i thought it would
help help help
oh i've got him cool my flintlock ain't
doing much
ow help any day now i had a bow out man
we are worse at combat than we were when
we didn't have everything
god mark you look awful do i look like
you yeah we look the same
but you got bone armor yeah you got
bones oh wait why do you guys have
fleshy flesh
put on the flesh oh
we wouldn't be as god as possible the
bones look good i look like you now i'm
on the team
god dammit there's a
rope down here why do i even have to
climb rope still
honestly oh there's
eyeballs on this thing oh if you look at
your right shoulder
right arm oh god oh yeah that was nice
oh god we gotta do the climbing thing
this is
what is this how can we cheat our way up
this wall huh
i feel like we're descending into hell
like the pits of tartar is here
not an armed century music starts
playing uh
i'm going to be very concerned we do
look pretty god-awful
that came out of the darkness it's very
scary it's not scary to you guys now
oh my god all right one lock boom
does not do as much okay well they
didn't like that did you see the way it
fell down
no but i saw it uh it was all
and then dead all right got another one
hey
hey are you running why are you running
[Applause]
well this looks weird why is it brightly
lit down here
i have ten thousand and one old
gun ammo oh that should be enough
wow this looks ominous in red i'm not
sure why
there's a strange amount of light down
here in the depths of hell
oh is this where we use on the door
this is where we use on doors there's a
door you will use on door here
oh wait do you bob you want the honors
uh how in god's name am i supposed to
find a key card
top left yeah oh okay
oh i got it there we go we'll cover the
entrance whatever comes through there
guys i'm using on door door all right
i'm watching you use this on the door
oh i'm frozen
what oh no that's too clean i'll go
first
all right i'm alive this is yeah it's
like the whole way from resident evil
where the ladies
seems good oh it's one of those grabby
things that's a rope never mind
oh no a rope a half-life grabby thing oh
no
from yeah half-life i think we go up the
grabby thing
i think the rope is the way i took the
paint though i painted it to myself
why yeah they'll never
ah this makes sense yeah i knew it i'll
just make sure you guys knew it how did
they build all this down here what is
what is all this cannibals sure have
some refined engineering
yeah they're good at their design bouncy
love how these just
always kind of oh cut off random places
oh oh the door opened oh this cross is
on the wall that
hey what the hell hey okay so
nice little girl's missing magina school
photo well i guess i guess i'm not
coming back up guys so i hope this is
the right way hi
mark hi i was just learning about story
stuff don't worry
all right cool oh what the hell oh weird
did you go left right away mark did you
go straight down the big hallway to the
right he went
left oh creepy well there's something
down to the right
yeah that's the normal way to go
tells lies mickey do tell lies if you
think about it mine's an empty dead-end
a [ __ ] liar that was an empty dead
end there's no way
no way bro there's no way bro bro
wait you're kind of dumb turn it up
yeah there's an up oh hey there's an up
uh what an empty guy
you didn't go to the end before deciding
empty dead end
i have declared it oh i can oh
i can use our money here i'm gonna shoot
this door
it didn't do nothing oh i see i see i've
dedicated hey
hey guys you guys want to come sit on a
company out of course i do
i can barely see it oh apparently only
one person oh wait nope i got it
oh sick good show old chaps well
i love your guys's suits really nice
thank you
i'm glad we got dressed up and gooped up
for this yeah
i don't like the way mine feels i like
the way it holds me
like is yours squeezing you this way so
what are we
this way what's this oh hey i'm sure
glad i have a flashlight on this flip
lock
really helpful
these are some very populated crouch
height
hallways this feels like a very
different game all of a sudden why is
this here
well yeah why oh oh
what oh here's the i found the babies
guys
oh oh no oh no yep well
less oh no more shoot them i guess but
yeah oh oh no
don't touch me oh no that's what i'm
feeling yeah
nothing no sympathy for the babies just
oh no
i didn't think that human
experimentation was going to be the the
center of the
amazing no i didn't either but uh here
we are okay
john don't look so good i'm just i just
gotta say
johnny uh has seen better days
uh-oh big one
big one coming big one coming big one
coming oh
john looks pretty awful i literally saw
into the ass crack
oh he's big one might be coming wait
down here big one was somewhere oh did i
kill big one
did i one shot bigger one holy [ __ ]
oh wait whoa whoa whoa
okay guys this is really unrelated all
those are awesome i think i'm about to
throw up i gotta be right back
okay bye all right i guess we just get
left staring at this wade
you and me great and all of these were
um uh children not all of them
based on the beds i would say most of
them were
oh this does not bode well for bob's kid
no doesn't bode well so from what i can
gather is
the people that are up there there must
be some kind of like either virus or
chemical that they injected these people
with it causes their bodies to not only
mutate but also combined in strange ways
um and maybe it's like a progressive
thing where it's neural
neurological degeneration and whatnot
but yeah that ain't good because i don't
see that
that right there i don't see that as
being like a bunch of things
combined into one i see that as like one
grew into a million things
you know teratoma like we talked about
it on distractible
our podcast that we have together yeah
hi
hi hello i wanted to let you know that
there's a link down in the description
below that leads to bob wade and i's new
podcast
well i say new it's been out for a few
weeks
but in case you haven't heard of it and
you like the content that bob wade and i
do
you can check it out for yourself it's
got a lot of funny discussions where we
just get an excuse to get together every
week and talk about whatever we want
it's just more content completely free
open to you accessible at any time
on any platform that you can find
podcasts click that link down there in
the description below
it's easy to do or go to
distractiblepodcast.com that's
d-i-s-t-r-a-i-b-l-e-p-o-e-d
here ash.com
c-a-s-t that's how you spell cast i know
how to spell that
anyway back to the forest distractible i
farmed all this by the way in my
inventory i farmed it
um yeah we talked about the teratoma on
like one of the first episodes it was uh
terrible actually hey hey bob
you all right oh my god i just threw up
so hard
are you good oh i don't know man
i was fine and then all of a sudden my
body was just like
this [ __ ] needs to get the [ __ ] out
right now fair enough you need to
and you need to bail holy lord no i
think i actually feel way better having
thrown up everything but like
oh yeah i think i'm okay but like holy
[ __ ] just don't look to your left as you
progress
yeah don't look oh yeah you didn't even
notice this before you left
no i literally walked in this hallway
and this my brain was just like
[ __ ] that is pretty gross though i like
the arms and
whatever legs sticking up yeah well i
was talking about like
i think there's some kind of teratoma
thing going on here where they're
injected
you know what that might make me throw
up again i'm going to stop looking this
never mind goddamn that's nasty
that's kind of territorial on the stairs
you get that mark
property of megan megan is not my son
why the [ __ ] do i care
hmm draw your favorite thing mm-hmm okay
yeah
bye megan who's who's playing jams what
is this
oh we're headed into the party zone
apparently
oh what the hell oh
subject
parents willing to spend money oh
somebody just left their presentation
going i see
yeah very matthew cross wasn't megan's
last name cross was this his own
daughter virginia
multiple sexual organs face distortion
multiple oh
oh cool oh i think it said megan cross
and dr cross i think his own daughter
was one
oh so they were doing lovely science
stuff here pure science
hey look at this thing oh it's the
yeah it's the the artifact yeah so they
either found something alien or they
made something or derived it from
something that they found
either way there's something here that's
kind of alien-esque are we infected
probably okay definitely we wrapped
we're wearing hell on our bodies yeah
protected us from anything weird that
might touch us
you're right you're right you're right
oh oh my favorite
this hi matt your play with sarah's
terminated front that's cool and
inappropriate something
who did one now on the printer
matt got fired oh yeah matt got fired
hey guys you could drink from the water
cooler
hey there's a dude here hi bud
hey pal oh is that matt
[Laughter]
i messed him up well this explains how
there's so many people on this island i
guess
yeah definitely let's hope that oh there
it is
oh it's like the marker from dead space
oh oh this is terrifying it's just a
dead space universe game
oh hey you guys hearing some whispering
from this thing this kind of sounds like
a really sick
uh edm song actually ooh to second
artifact oh that's nice
well there seems to be some kind of a
door here if you guys want me to try to
open it
all right all right let's see oh am i
doing something on your screen
no oh yeah oh god
oh oh my god
hey buddy you all right oh my god
uh uh i'm devastated
at this oh my god
it's my son so this is kind of awkward
yeah i'm sorry that i'm doing this
for your son i apologize oh what am i
doing i don't like that i don't what
[Music]
well i mean
no no i knew how you felt about like you
know
any kind of physical contact with your
child i knew how you felt about that so
like i thought i'd just do the honors so
you wouldn't have to oh
okay well he does not look like he's
doing very well i gotta
put him on that table i'm on the life
table
all right there you go bob are you gonna
save them
what you doing oh how about giving you a
toy i guess
oh you just gave him nothing on my
screen that's good
oh no
[Music]
i um god we really built up to this
moment guys
did you kill my son no but there's these
weird tubes
i think i have an idea i didn't yeah
yeah yeah
i'm gonna plug
you know it's good this guy is telling
me what to do the the plug knows it's on
his arm okay that one knows
okay yep plugs i trust this
technicals
[Music]
oh i don't volunteer for this i
i think you need to climb in no no no no
no no no
i'm i'm not uh you know what to do
you're right i don't know what to do no
no no no no
yeah you're you're a son you're
oh that megan girl yeah let's go fine
i'm gonna give you a little [ __ ]
douche
yeah i need to replace my batteries
man i do not have a tough time aiming
this thing how do you uh how do you
replace the batteries again
don't know no idea oh okay i've been
able to do it
who needs a light well oh
uh this looks official and important
oh there's another little drawing here
daddy's angry
i don't even see where is the flashlight
it's on the left-hand side by the
hairspray in the tennis racket wait yeah
my flashlight's on now so if you do
combine
oh what the hell uh guys
what uh guys
yeah well look at that
look at the caves underneath oh wait hey
kid
kid megan oh wait
oh megan don't look so good wait no back
up megan
why am i approaching yeah mark no
i'm choosing not to do this you better
get megan no i don't wanna mark you're
gonna you're gonna grab her
uh on grammar oh hi
uh again
is she mad or something no oh she's
doing zoomies
oh oh the plane crashed oh look how
happy daddy looks in there
don't point at me she points
[Music]
oh i don't like that did you kill her no
oh
okay over here
mark you got this why does it do
that
yeah i don't know oh that's long limbs
guys i don't know if you know but
there's a thing have you seen the thing
yeah
i might have seen it it's it's in the
top right corner of the room
what did it just do oh it's on it's
spawned babies it's
the babies they're coming why don't you
wait for this one moment to do this
megan
why why is the music so intense right
now
yeah god damn this is so loud i told you
guys we have explosives
don't worry i'll kill the babies so you
guys got the rest of this thanks thanks
man thanks it's got wade
okay good it'll definitely stay still
long enough
okay cool i'm hooking another one okay
good
another one i'm hooking more okay keep
oh
okay point blank i don't care mark move
mark move i am whoa
all right you know what i'll also hook
explosives
explosives [ __ ] i
oh no i'm gonna try this head bomb out
all right do it oh yeah do it oh that's
going to work
that way
grabbing my head bomb hucking my head
bomb
good all right it ran away from my head
yeah no it ran away it wasn't your
throat was short good thing we painted
ourselves before this before
babies don't worry
oh good good good head good head back
oh i'm getting my i don't have any more
head bombs how'd you make head bombs uh
there we go
look out i i don't know how you make
head bombs but you threw like 15 of them
before
no those were the regular explosives do
you have a bunch of regular explosives
where
on the left side by the way
i'm going to light some molotovs to try
and ignite it went to the far end
throwing it in just get it get it yeah
you get backed up against that corner
you'll never get away
yes yes yes i'm blowing it up
oh oh dude nice oh it's on fire it's on
fire it's on fire
i don't like the meat tornado
stay back oh hey
there's a thing over there oh my god wow
okay one of you guys can get
uh mark i think you need to talk to
megan why do i need to talk
to your doctor not my my child yours
mine okay yeah well the boy is mine so
this must be your child
we saved her so we could go yeah clearly
clearly megan is doomed so this is a
murderer i wear some of these stalks as
armor can i take these with me
i'm gonna go shove this cursed child in
a big
iron maiden okay and i'm not gonna feel
bad about it in any way shape or form
you hear that megan you hear the the
call of your buddies
all right uh just go ahead and toss
around in there
in there close those doors up i'm going
to throw and then walk away i'm
definitely not going to
[ __ ] [ __ ] run no i'm wait uh whoa
she kind of just floats in that's fine
she looks so hot look how casual she is
yeah oh oh oh oh no you're getting
you're gonna hang her up right yeah live
sample required wait
live sample oh mark
all right put her in better no no no
yeah
mark i think you go ahead and put your
gun down i think i got this key card
that's not the end why isn't that the
end i want that to be the end well
there's another key card over here that
we put over here and then
there's a second artifact didn't you
know
is the second artifact some sort of live
sample yeah probably
i don't know my problem probably this
place looks great over here
yeah very great oh dude the rocks came
in hell yeah
oh wait something like burrowed over
here oh god
oh yeah oh yeah let's explore this oh
goodness
right now to go out i'll replace
batteries oh there's a climbing wall
over here
oh yeah that they were supposed to
climb up okay
bend your knees when you land no i
didn't need to
i got drugs oh wow this goes deeply
yeah i i don't know about the design
choices of the path to artifact too but
this is uh
interesting we never did try the door at
the end of the hall we kind of just saw
a hole and we're like let's go for it
you're right we didn't
try hey we're going we're adventuring
come on now
yeah it's all part of the investigative
mark's daughter yeah wait what
you guys will never believe what's up
ahead what's up ahead stuff
a perfect it's a perfect pathway to a
door oh well this isn't where we were so
it's fine hey
heads oh
that's less that's less good oh no
that's icky
it's a little icky i'm not 100 sure how
this happened
did something stampede their way through
here and uh
cause a ruckus or did these bodies just
kind of explode
oh
oh god was there something behind us no
no i was just like
the doors closed i thought i was going
to be on my own again oh
whoa what okay what
this idea oh you can't go over there
okay look there's where we lived
huh oh then you would have been able to
see this from me oh my god
guys there's longs in here i don't like
that sound
oh that's water though
oh emergency shut down button over here
uh maybe not
oh three matches identified oh my god
they were
targeting flames don't press that button
i
if i'm gonna be stranded on the island i
want other people to happen
there are three children on that plane
that we could
kidnap oh
it would be morally reprehensible
or we could shut it all down and if we
shut it all down
you don't have to be a parent anymore
that's true this literally overlooks
our home how do we not see this guys i
we never really looked up
very much we also never came into the
snow we completely dodged the snow
yeah look how close our house was to the
pit
in the grand scheme of things i know
look at that that's weird
it's a great spot whoever picked that
spot some kind of genius it was a great
spot
a fantastic spot oh wait you picked it
wade
yeah oh nice work dude
oh wait no that's our temporary shelter
our other house is over
uh to the left there well i felt good
about myself for a minute that was nice
you know what wade you did it we did
have a pretty good spot
we couldn't really be attacked at our
house that was kind of nice yeah it was
good
so wait a minute
or something i mean i'm always down for
that but i think we need a vote here to
really decide what goes on
all right well what do you vote king of
the castle well since
i personally feel like
it's like three kids there we could not
only
fix your son but fix megan and that'd
probably be cool
with a kid to spare interesting shutdown
is also an option and then you know
i don't think that means we go home
though what's your son's name bob
yeah what's your son's name [ __ ] i
don't know why would i know that
all right well i say we shut down and
remember his kid's name
okay so that's one vote plain one vote
for shut down trying to get the deciding
vote right now yeah i think you got to
go
what are the names of these people this
sally
you're not going to have anything well
look one of them's in first class
that one deserves it one of them is in
the bathroom
they're not doing so well one of them
has an exit row seat
no these people are douche i think we
should take it down all right all right
that's the boat all right uh activate
oh double you do it twice let's do it
twice all three of us have to do it
twice yeah let me bring up the
the photo too
looking at my sweet baby
gather up let's put these puzzle pieces
together here everyone look at this bowl
you never seen my beautiful baby boy i'm
the only one in
i'm the only one in no no i was in no
kids ever been lucky enough to have
three dads before two out of three all
right
oh i gotta do two all of us have to do
it oh well there we go
oh we are one now
we have become ultra
ah the time has come oh my god what are
we wearing
why do we have a big helmet head well
that's shadow i don't know oh
maybe not nah
[ __ ] it this is for you uh
whatever your name is
[Music]
timmy was the son named timmy sure
oh what a sound how do we know that the
plane's going to land perfectly on the
island
ours did that's true that's true
here she comes whoa
i'm glad our glass is unbreakable by a
plane fitting it hey
it contains an alien artifact it's
probably pretty strong
all right you got me when you got me you
know when you got it not yet
um are you guys still unconscious
i'm yeah i'm taking a nap oh one oh
that was a long nap oh [ __ ] are we king
of this island
oh my god i hope we are my next guest is
a tv star
author and real life plane crash
survivor
what here talk to us about his new book
rescue
calm down kiddo
[Applause]
oh my god it's an axe
oh my god it's an axe is happening what
is this
show i don't know you're okay
kid ah he's a little twitchy for my
taste
yeah that's too way too crazy
i feel like you're really blurry what's
our
hey do y'all want a demonstration you
want demonstration
we've got a setup right over here what
what what devon's what oh
hey guys you're gonna love this what do
you say
timmy what do you have to say come on
everyone
[Music]
all right yes start killing them with
the axe oh
okay all right kid don't worry about the
thing
what have we done
[Music]
oh that's not how you got your own axe
like this yeah
oh okay this is great tv guys
i like how we're blocking the log from
the camera and facing our back
oh oh
oh oh oh
he's fine he does this he'll start
spitting out extra legs here in a second
well i don't know why everyone is
screaming a kid's having a seizure and
people suddenly start screaming yeah
if someone needs to give him some
medical attention i think we didn't even
get to watch him oh here we go
legs we're back again oh oh oh
oh maybe he's not maybe he's actually
just needs medical attention yeah i
think he was actually just having a
seizure there and uh
no it's about to be a jump scare hundred
percent oh okay i wouldn't do that to us
perfect he's fine yeah
we did it and everything turned out okay
best indeed
our actions have no consequences we have
to be famous
yeah oh god oh we're no you know
and how oh okay endings are there
[Music]
hell yeah wow that was fast what a
[ __ ]
mess hell yeah oh hey
timmy oh [ __ ]
what'd you do to us you little [ __ ]
life hasn't been the same since i
murdered my dad
you should have left me on that [ __ ]
island oh
sight too huh hmm interesting obsessed
much
timmy brushed whiskey damn he's got the
good stuff
that's the way uh-huh oh
oh oh i don't like the arm
that's not good no i don't like the iron
guys fine don't worry about the arm
balls
they're all good you survived this long
timmy hold it in another 80 years
yeah see he's good dude timmy's good
he seemed to be holding it together yeah
he was good
all right yay i mean honestly that seems
like because it looked like all the map
stuff he was looking up at
like another site says something about a
sequel so i'm sure there's more
and that was the true ending of course
it was hello i never thought that we
would beat
the forest we did it guys well i would
like to thank uh
us and our collective hive mind for
getting through this yeah definitely
me for my great home placement
did you guys do anything no all right
well thank you guys
um and thank you everybody for listening
go look up distractible
it's our podcast check it out on spotify
or apple pie yeah you should watch it
good you should definitely watch it all
right
well take care everybody yeah bye
everybody
yeah bye